це колись був
село мільйонер а тепер
максимум там 20 з невеликим будинків житлових
все і стільки ж людей чоловік 20
мазена не аптеці ні медпункту
увага чого тут до цього я багато живий
бовтається ми продали там квартиру і тд
ринку захотілося землю обробляти
мені треба творити був вона мені дала вам
можливість це все робити але дихало я
не сказала а що не заважало те та ну і
взагалі-то я з нею і радився завжди і
потім вона сказала ось мені зробити вакули
я зробив це і юльки
а я ніколи сама дати їм не задумався і
це сутність вже людини має бути
щось робити робити я почав п'ять років
вже мене матчі стільки ось ці ось рази
коси з довгою треба бажати бажати
творчості тя щоб було ух ти це не від
кішки закриваючи вона відкриває і кидає
відчинені двері назад не закривають це
спина plaza
беру шматки зроблю як бруски і більше
щоб були
прямокутної щоб були квадрати всі та
склеюю
а потім ніж у руки все більше ніяких
інструментів тільки ніжки
то в мене ніхто не вчив щось журналом
журналу писав художник це можна сказати
улюблена картина чому саша хотів у неї
виразити обличчя я висловив це
відчужений погляд і думаючи про те, що
буде з ним мені подобається краса і як
раніше
радянському союзі зневажливо
говорили салонний живопис вважалося так
красивість
красиво все а тепер між іншим як
раз салонна то живність та попитом
користується
ну ось обличчя припустимо ми схожого там же
нічого немає але тут є посмішка я
прагнув зробити але не таку, щоб вона
там це все-таки боротьба непристойного
широко рот вибуху але все-таки що то
можна було взяти в неї
але не так відкритий рот, але ось такому
дусі я роблю все не означає що я копію
до
не вважайте за розбещення взагалі-то але я
виписав ось такий журнал створив
жінку найкрасивіша істота не потрібна
ось раз і відстані допустимо ось ці
ось ці відстані та інше шию там все
габарит у мене немає натурниці
поч я беру ось таких одну дозу більше
видно мерію та виводжу середня і тоді
роблять добре б якби була на
творчість або там навіть руку пальця та
тупаєш ніде взяти
завжди кажучи заліку їх не продав на
виставках бував там сорочинському ярмарку
звичайно знаємо ціну
але не хочу я їх продавати і все
вони лежить їх продавати ну дрібно мені
здається продати і тому що я багато
витрачають на ньому енергії
душу скарби і вона вже щоб люди бачили
захоплювалися там чи знайомі щось
знаходили для цього він вже як я сказав
горіти він спалахнув я зробити культури я
і зроблю добре зробили але наступне
якщо ви мене доживу
буде то взагалі бій
[музика]